what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with dark ages but i do need
your all's help did we ever finish
marvel overture where nightmare
basically kills the marvel universe did
we ever finish that i know we did part
one but i can't remember if we finished
it at all let me know down in the
comments section it'd be greatly
appreciated because if we did then i'm
gonna make a full story out of it so
here's the thing uh this initially picks
up well really with kind of a fun little
moment
before everybody realizes that tony
stark is essentially missing and what we
end up getting here is basically johnny
storm using his power to heat a tea
kettle
and talking to the children none of whom
know who galactus is which is weird
because he's like you've never heard of
galactus and they're like no i mean
who's galactus it's kind of like it's a
tea party man spider-man's like no no
dude they're kids they don't need to
know about galactus
we don't need to be concerned with that
right now and so everybody just kind of
goes about and continues doing their own
thing but ultimately of course you end
up having this revelation given to
everybody that tony stark has
disappeared and pepper potts of course
is the one that helps everybody kind of
figure out what's going on but
ultimately she can only offer so much
help but with x23 right laura kitty
wolverine with her being there and her
ability to track sense that's when she
realizes right off the bat this was no
accident that tony stark was taken by
mystique because as far as pepper was
concerned it was steve rogers but again
mystique can duplicate people so unless
you have the kind of senses that uh that
x-23 has that laura kinney has you're
never gonna actually know that's the
case now of course we also know that
stark was teleported away and that's
essentially when the trail goes cold and
so from that point it's a conversation
between like doctor doom and like like
lunella lafayette and black panther and
all these guys where it's kind of like
okay we have to figure out what to do
now this is one of the things i love the
most about this story because as you
guys know i am an avid apocalypse fan
i'm just a huge apocalypse fan i have
been ever since x-men the animated
series he was always my favorite villain
i love seeing episodes with him the cool
thing about this is what you're talking
about are people who are incredibly
powerful specifically doctor do but he's
probably the most powerful person in
this room right now with his ability to
manipulate magic sorcery alchemy all
kinds of different stuff and so what he
says here is that like when it comes to
tony stark he's not simply just a means
by which they can generate some new form
of technology or something like that he
says like if apocalypse is taking stark
we have to recover him immediately and
when the statement's made like i'm
surprised to hear you say that kind of
thing ultimately he says and really
lunella chimes in and says the same
thing that like tony stark's mind was
built for destruction right like he's
the greatest weapon maker to ever to
have ever lived and so in a lot of ways
it is concerned about the power of
apocalypse to a degree but more so than
that is the concern for what tony stark
could end up building for apocalypse and
that's their biggest concern here the
other part about this is that that tony
stark as far as dr doom is concerned is
a ticking time bomb but what's really
cool here is what's not said and it's
really the threat that apocalypse poses
what we end up getting here is really
doctor doom just kind of being like we
can't rush in and face off against
someone like apocalypse one because of
the the technology that he has at his
disposal right the kind of things that
he's likely engineered out there in
europe but two the power that he has and
when it comes to apocalypse as a villain
he has been portrayed different ways and
pretty inconsistently over the years but
whenever he's portrayed at like the peak
of his abilities it is very difficult to
kill him and he is by all standards of
measurement like an impossible to kill
guy right a guy that just cannot be
readily destroyed you know it's just the
kind of level of power that he possesses
remember he channels celestial
technology and so the crazy thing about
this is that with doctor doom ultimately
stepping in and making this declaration
it's well then we have to do something
right we have to do something about this
whole thing like we can't simply rush
into this it's the exact same thing that
black panther says and so what they say
is like we need a scout we need somebody
who can get in there they can see what's
going on and they can get out fast and
so what they end up doing is sending
quick silver now as a guy who runs at
almost 200 miles per hour he can get in
there pretty quickly but he can get in
there really really fast see what's
going on and then get out just as fast
the funny thing about this and the way
that peter parker explains it here is he
says the idea was that quicksilver would
be in and out of the base before anyone
ever knew he was there faster than even
apocalypse could detect him and he could
have done just that if it wasn't for
what he discovered and in realizing that
magneto that his father is being held
captive by apocalypse and being used as
what's in effect an energy source the
first thing he wanted to do was free his
father now initially you might look at
that and say okay well this is kind of
ridiculous but it's actually not the
history of quicksilver in terms of how
he's been written in marvel comics is
he's always been reckless a really good
example of this is a story called son of
m during the events of house of emp and
i don't know if we ever covered this and
if we didn't we certainly should but son
of m it was really more part of
decimation than it was house of m but it
was the aftermath right with all these
different mutants losing their powers
that what quicksilver did is he ran to
uh to attend he went to the city of
attending in human city and stole their
terrigen crystals or at least some of
them and then used them to activate or
try to reactivate mutant powers it was a
reckless decision it wasn't fully
thought out but that's always been the
nature of pietro maximoff and so him
just kind of racing off to try to rescue
his dad and giving no real thought to
the bigger picture here is exactly
something he would do and so ultimately
when he tries to approach the device
containing magneto of course he's
shocked he's not destroyed but when the
question is like okay like what do we do
here we end up learning that otto
octavius had actually predicted this he
had predicted that what was going to
happen is the heroes were going to send
somebody in here to figure out what's
going on and most likely it would be
quicksilver because he's the only person
that could get in here and out fast
enough before anybody could even detect
that he was there and so the the
question that otto asked is like should
we lock him away with the others the
response of apocalypse is no don't do
that let's send him back and so they
ultimately put him under the control of
the purple man they send him back in
there and when the question is like
could silver what have you learned
that's when people realize something's
not right and quicksilver being able to
move at 200 miles per hour right 175
technically being able to move so fast
he literally just kills so many people
he kills a koi he kills all these
individuals who were here not any of
like the huge mainstays but he kills
more than a few people he gets to the
point when he actually ends up impaling
johnny storm right to the point where
johnny swarms injured and can't control
his powers at that point gene grey
manages to step in and what's what we're
told here is it only took gene grey a
second to reach quicksilver's mind but
in that second he had already done so
much damage but she basically shuts his
mind down but in that moment literally
johnny storm is going haywire he can't
keep his power contained he can't
control it and that's what he tells him
you have to leave and the response of
susan storm is no i'm not going anywhere
right you're my brother i'm not leaving
you i'm staying here because as far as
she's concerned she seemingly lost
everything else right franklin's gone
reed's gone all that kind of stuff it's
literally just her and it's just johnny
and that's basically it there's really
nothing else there for them and so in
that moment of course she casts her
force field johnny storm ends up
exploding basically ends up dying in the
process and that's it right it's this
massive weight of guilt that she has
hanging over her that she couldn't save
her own brother and even more so than
that the guilt weighs over her that she
couldn't save reed she couldn't save
valeria she couldn't save franklin or
anything but as far as she's concerned
she was just a complete and total
failure because she couldn't save the
people that were closest to her and so
at that point of course once pietro is
taken to the hospital and basically is
allowed to wake up because he wasn't
operating of his own accord they can't
really punish him here right like
literally he went on a mission they sent
him on and he was overtaken by the
purple man who they didn't know operated
with apocalypse so you can't really
fault him too much and so he ends up of
course apologizing to sue and saying i'm
sorry i didn't mean for all this to
happen and even jessica jones comes to
his aid and says like i know what it's
like to have the purple man screwing
with your head and so when the question
is asked what did you see there that's
when he starts spilling all the beans
and he's like they have a like a pyramid
full of electricity that they have
magneto in the middle of it and that's
literally when when people start putting
together they're building a faraday cage
right which is basically a way to kind
of keep the emp at bay to sort of keep
this this uh electromagnetic pulse from
taking out power in that immediate area
but then at that point he's just like
yeah i saw tony stark you know they're
basically working on something and not
just tony stark hank mccoy dr octopus
riri williams reed richards like they're
all working with apocalypse and that's
when susan storm just refuses to believe
it because she's like there's no way my
husband reed would willingly work with
apocalypse right there's there's no way
that would that would willingly happen
of course from our perspective what we
know is that reed is doing it because
he's under the control of the purple man
seemingly everybody else there is which
really begs the question if zebedee
kilgrave can ensnare all of them why
hasn't zebedee kilgrave ensnared
apocalypse yet that's the question that
you have to ask here or has he already
done it and so at this point what you
end up doing is switching that back over
to apocalypse himself where he's just
kind of laying in weight right and just
having all the experience he has in
terms of battle strategy in terms of all
that stuff he literally just says like
they're going to be coming and they're
going to try to stop us and some kind of
disembodied a person says like they're
not going to succeed and so he asks are
the three of you ready and the response
is yes we are ready to hunt in essence
he's talking to like this new symbiote
which is basically bonded to somebody
right like this literal modified semi
like a three in one symbiote which is
just crazy
what do you think about it and so it's
nuts to see but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end i can't wait to get to the next one
because this one's kind of the slower
one uh this one and the next one are a
little bit slow and then once you get to
uh well once you get after that then it
all just really starts to blow up but
we're gonna bring this to an end thank
you all for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace